Let's discuss the solution for our performance
reporting quiz. We need to check, among these,
all of those that use codes from real
applications, but not all of the code. Peak
performance doesn't use any code. Synthetic benchmarks do
not use code from real applications. This is
code specifically designed for testing. Application kernels do
use code from real applications but that application
code has been reduced to form a kernel,
so this is definitely true. An application suite
uses the code from real applications and uses
all of the code for these applications. So,
this is not true. And then, an actual
workload mix is similar to an application suite
except that it comes from usage patterns of
a specific user. So, the answer to this quiz
is that application kernels use code from
reapplication, but not all of their code.